gorgeous leftover super flower moon out  there it is it was so nice and full but  we had a lot of clouds around last night  did you see the lunar eclipse we've  gotten a few pictures in locally and  then we've got a great video this is  from nasa we rolled a time lapse on it  as you could see that the earth's shadow  completely covered up the moon last  night over all of north america  and then it kind of turned that reddish  reddish glow as it was in totality so  really a pretty super moon and lunar  eclipse but we had clouds around last  night so it obscured a lot of the lunar  eclipse hopefully you were able to get  out and see some of it last night we